I made it to bigger object they were
both made from you know two cups of
espresso one of them glued like it and
other one goes like this so this one I
can balance very carefully like this one
at the port where is the other one I
have really no chance of balancing and
today I'm stable so you might have the
impression that this one is the stable
one and this one is the unstable one
because this you know bulges out and hug
whatever support it so standing onwards
this is on a skip well let's do the
dynamic version of the experiment so
this is an inclined plane and we'll try
to let this roll down the slope here we
go and it rolls down and goes all the
way down very happily next this one
let's try to make it roll down the slope
and when I do that oops it went off the
rails however hard I try to Center it it
really doesn't want to go all the way
down it's very very very difficult to
have me almost made it but not quite no
it doesn't why is this such a good
roller all the way down and why is this
such an unstable roller the difference
is very very interesting and it has to
do with one of the most fundamental if
simplest ideas in science and
engineering which really is at the heart
of today's technology called stability
and instability let's first look at this
one well I thought I can Center this
thing exactly in the middle well that's
fine goes straight down low stays on
there is no problem there that you know
in nature
you always make mistakes so there is
some error initial error let's say dirty
hazard slightly to the left like this so
it's now deviated strategy but in that
case you see this thing is going to be
supported on the Left rail here and on
the right rail here that is on the left
it's rolling on effectively a wheel that
has a large radius on the here it's
effectively rolling on a wheeled as
small radius so you have a large wheel
on this side and small wheel on this
side and you know what they are going to
do it's going to start deviating right
word in other words in
at the council the initial error to the
left so this is a restoring mechanism or
an automatic correction mechanism
whenever there is a slight deviation to
the left this system automatically
corrects itself by going right and if it
deviates a little bit to the right
it's the same thing the other way around
is that's automatically going to the
left so there's an automatic correction
mechanism that's why it's so stable what
kind of big one just prolongs y:real use
and what what what's the physical thing
because if you have a small wheel on
this side and large wheel on this side
and if they roll both at at the same
time you see / same amount of angular
roll this small advance a small distance
and large one advance a large distance
so you see this one goes a little but
this one goes large so it starts curving
in this direction and if you have a
small one on this side and large one
instead it's the other way start curving
on side so whichever side is smaller
that side is the side toward which the
whole thing starts weeding yeah they're
connected yeah yeah they're connected
that's right okay so that's why this
thing is such a stable roller because
whenever there is an initial error which
is inevitable it automatically is
collecting its course so while it's
wobbling around the center it can safely
go down in contrast this one is a
disaster because again you know if you
can if you can at all Center it in the
middle there is no problem if you go
straight down but that's only idealized
scenario in practice there's always some
intro error let's add before assume that
there's a slight error to the left but
then you see the left part of this
object is supported here on this rail so
it's rolling on a small wheel whereas
the right part is supported here which
is rolling on a large wheel so whenever
it's deviating slightly to the left you
have a small wheel on the Western
knowledge widow on the right and you
know what those wheels will do they'll
start moving towards that so if there's
a an initial left error there will be a
tendency to start going even further
left
so the error grows and grows and goes
out of control and eventually of course
the whole thing moves off the rails so
there is a mechanism which is opposite
what we had before that is whenever
there is a small initial error which is
inevitable there is some mechanism
devilish mechanism that makes the error
grow and grow and that is called an
instability and in general in abstract
terms whenever there is a system that we
want to control or something that nature
gives and you know there are some
initial errors in be into positioning
well if the error has a tendency to
diminish there is an automatic
collection mechanism that system is
stable and if the error tends to grow
and goes out of control
that's unstable mechanism and that is
why this can hardly go down this earth
whereas this is very very stable I think
that keeps going down first anyone
watching is immediately right now going
start picking that triangle may have the
triangle work so if the train is going
straight there is no problem but suppose
if you wants to round the corner and it
has a wheel let's say on this side and
the other way one side and they're
connected as it goes round the corner
the distance that this outer wheel has
to travel is actually longer than the
distance that this inner will have to
travel so there's a problem because they
are rotating at the same rate one of
them are skid and that's a very bad bus
station so they cannot both role because
distance is they are different so how do
you correct for this this effect as long
as the wheels are connected it seems to
be completely uncomfortable as
difficulty but there is a really nice
mechanism here is what you should do
effectively you should put this kind of
design on the tail rails you see so when
it wants to go around the corner the
centrifugal force makes this go slightly
outside but that's very good news
because as long as it's owned outside
that part of the wheel becomes effective
larger and this part is actually smaller
so the distances that they travel are
automatically adjusted and indeed outer
wheel does travel longer distance and
you know a shorter distance and because
the wheel radii are different and of
course in a real train wheel it doesn't
look like that but actually the design
kind of look like this in cross-section
this is sitting on the rail like this
and this is sitting on the rail a cliff
so as the Lobos Destin right the
effecting wheel size varies and that
automatically adjusts for the stable
rounding of corner it's really a
wonderful thing and by the way if you
designed the wheels in this fashion that
would be really a disaster train that is
easy to become of the rail just as this
couldn't go down the rope
I wonder if I can
go down all the way
[Music]
[Laughter]
one way to do it for my point of view
the right hand and pull it over and then
do this which produces a perpendicular